with stubbornly low levels of growth and
continued lack of competitiveness in
many European economies social dumping
is a burning issue this is when
enterprises undermine local traditional
labor markets and their social levels by
using cheaper often migrant workers for
production or by moving production to a
low-wage third country then importing
their products sassani salafi a key
funny Fred Lynn axio to certain governo
more facile a from structural I really
see if a so dumping sociale que existe
mallu hos- horizontal please guava puso
develop a benefic deneuve even more
fiscal social favorable aquino suup APPA
ali zeppeli zeppeli zoo at September's
plenary session mep s argued social
dumping leads to big distortions of the
single market they want such measures as
letterbox companies which injure the
prospects of SMEs band how is it
possible to realize radius
industrialization when we are going or
we are dealing with so many free trade
agreements that are offering so many
advantages to other countries from the
whole world and it's even cheaper to
produce in those countries instead of
producing inside the European Union they
want increase domestic and cross-border
labour controls and inspections and
better information exchange more logical
view de paga social element know if you
can or prefer this is what's known as an
own initiative report which can only
encourage the Commission to act not
force it
suitable